un gran avance político tras años de
debates polarizados la Unión Europea
llegó a un acuerdo para renovar la
acogida y reubicación de solicitantes de
asilo inmigrantes Suecia que ejerce la
presidencia rotatoria del Consejo de la
Unión Europea ha celebrado este
importante Paso
hoy hemos dado un paso histórico tras
muchos años de negociaciones hoy hemos
dado este importante paso hacia una
legislación estable y sostenible sobre
migración
la prioridad de los países de la Unión
Europea es repartir más equitativamente
la acogida de los solicitantes de asilo
ya que muchos llegan a países de la
periferia principalmente Grecia e Italia
el acuerdo garantizaría en primer lugar
que se realice el trámite de
determinados solicitantes de asilo
inmediatamente en la frontera y
facilitará la devolución de aquellos
cuyo pedido sea rechazado los países
también tendrán que aceptar un
determinado número de de asilo y en caso
de negarse tendrán que pagar 20.000
euros por persona a un fondo gestionado
por Bruselas pero aún hay que pulir
algunos detalles incluida la cuestión de
A dónde enviar los solicitantes
rechazados la ampliación de los llamados
países Seguros A los que pueden regresar
siguen debate con el comisario europeo
de interior diciendo que aún no hay una
decisión tomada este acuerdo allana el
camino a unas difíciles negociaciones
con el parlamento y la comisión de la
Unión Europea para ultimar todo el
paquete antes de las elecciones europeas
del próximo año